this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
a woman's reproductive system includes
the vagina
cervix
uterus fallopian tubes
and ovaries
during vaginal sex between a man and a
woman semen passes out of the man's
penis into the woman's vagina in a
process called ejaculation
semen contains tens of millions of sperm
from the vagina sperm can pass through
the cervix
uterus
and fallopian tubes
to fertilize an egg from the woman's
body
fertilization of the egg marks the
beginning of human development
a birth control sponge is a temporary
method for women to prevent pregnancy
also known as birth control or
contraception
the sponge is made of soft foam it has a
dimple on one side
and a short cotton loop attached
the sponge prevents pregnancy in two
ways
first the sponge covers the woman's
cervix to prevent sperm in the man's
semen from entering her uterus
second the sponge contains a substance
called spermicide that kills sperm
birth control sponges are widely
available without a prescription
to use a sponge
wash your hands
remove it from its package
wet the sponge completely with clean
water
squeeze the wet sponge a few times to
activate the spermicide inside the
sponge
next hold the sponge with the dimple
side facing up and fold the sponge
upward
with the loop hanging down insert the
folded sponge into the vagina
push the sponge as far into the vagina
as it will go with one or two fingers
when the sponge is released it will
unfold and cover the cervix
check with your fingers to make sure the
cervix is completely covered by the
sponge
and the loop hangs down in the vagina
a woman can have sex right away
or up to 24 hours after inserting the
sponge
do not leave the sponge in place for
more than 30 hours
to remove it insert a finger into the
vagina to find the sponge's loop
hook a finger in the loop and pull down
slowly and gently
after removing the sponge throw it in
the trash
a birth control sponge is about 90
effective at preventing pregnancy if a
woman uses the sponge correctly every
time she has sex
this means about 10 out of 100 women
will become pregnant each year
sponges are about 85 percent effective
with typical use which means about 15
out of 100 women will become pregnant if
they don't always use a sponge or don't
always use it correctly every time they
have sex
using the sponge does not protect either
sexual partner from getting sexually
transmitted diseases including hiv